so obviously I'm a fan of both of your
work and I know everyone watching this
interview will have seen everything
however if someone is watching they've
never seen anything you've done besides
asteroid City what's the thing you want
them watching and why
um something that you have done yourself
yeah like from your previous from your
resume oh how interesting oh gosh
I don't know
um
maybe under the skin because I just I
think it's a great movie and I I'm
obsessed with Jonathan Blazer outside of
the work that I we did together but we
it was such a I think it's such a unique
movie
um that I would I want as many people to
see it as as possible because it's a
kind of a
little Hidden Gem so see a nice guy yeah
he's a great guy I loved his video he
did remember that rabbit in your
headlight video he did for the band
Uncle Tom York sleep remember that one
yeah I could sit back here it's great
what about you I would just say I don't
know I don't really have it I can't I I
have to yeah okay I have to sorry I
won't leave you uh
um uh someone who's never I would just
encourage them to see uh I don't know
I'm trying to think of something uh
uh uh Fantastic Mr Fox sure 100 yeah um
Scarlett individual question for you
um what was it like to finally get the
call from west to do live action
um it was great I was it was such an I
was in the middle of the quarantine time
and so it was basically the best I
received
um it just felt hopeful and like yeah so
you know there was something to look
forward to you know this kind of like
North Star thing and the light at the
end of a very weird tunnel
um and uh I was excited to read the
script and I know what the world was
that you know that he was sort of
playing in and then to get to have
creative conversations with him over
that time too just felt like so it felt
like I was working on something you know
developing and building something which
was again like a really welcome
distraction
um it was very exciting uh for both of
you a lot of people watching this will
be Wes Anderson film fans and I'm
curious what do you think might surprise
them to learn about the way Wes works on
set or in pre-production or just things
in general about West that maybe they
wouldn't know I think it's uh
as as
large as this cast is and as many people
as it took to to make the movie and and
how many people are involved
um I think it's you know it's surprising
to see how much he prefers an intimate
setting to actually start shooting the
movie doesn't like like prefer to have
just the actors and you know I mean like
to keep it kind of and I think that
that's like
but a very uh he goes he really makes it
clear and it's really cool because then
he never has to
he doesn't have to raise his but he's
just right there I think that's the
thing it's the feeling of intimacy in a
movie that looks you know it's got all
these people and it's on a big in a
crater and it's this big thing but it's
the process feels intimate I don't know
what would surprise anyone I don't know
what their assumptions are about West
but I um he's West has a very
um light positive excitable attitude
um on studies not you know sometimes if
you think of an alternative seem kind of
like serious and you know concentrated
and very particular that sets really
quiet whatever Wes is very Lively on set
um he makes noise while you're working
and hear him laughing and making noises
like he's really excited by the process
and he somehow has
more energy as the day goes on he's so
invigorated by work and he just works
constantly and he comes off the set he's
so excited about the work that you did
today that day he's already prepping for
the next it's just a it's a he's got so
he's so engaging and very funny and very
vivacious one of the things I'm curious
about is I would imagine Wes is very
specific with the way he wants you to
deliver dialogue and and also you're
acting to the camera move and you know
everything is so specific what is it
like as an actor where you are sort of
trying to you know bring his vision to
life versus maybe finding it on set with
a director who doesn't really exactly
know what they want
I don't think West knows exactly at my
experiences he doesn't actually know
what he wants out of the performance you
know you know the word there's a certain
you know the dialogue is the dialogue
and so that those are the kind of
parameters of this or if you have to hit
a specific Mark which you know is normal
right you have to say specific work this
maybe is a little bit more particular
but really that everything else is up
for grab so your whole interpretation of
what this means the color it you know
how it's colored the Nuance of it the
pause whatever it might be sometimes you
know he's like take a little air out of
it or you know he wants something to be
delivered in a more you know with sort
of kind of speed or this can be thrown
away or whatever but he's actually very
open to
you know what all filling it filling all
of the shading in of of all of it I
think that's what he like that's what he
loves about being there when you
describe his onset vivaciousness that is
the thing it's like this
the feeling of what's gonna happen you
don't have my theory is that as she says
he loves that I definitely have to talk
about the fact that you're voicing the
spot in spider verse so I just want to
say congrats on that thank you
um I want to know what can you tease for
the upcoming third movie which I know is
very limited but what can you tease and
also
um I've talked to Lorenzo about this
Transformers one and you get to voice a
character in this big CGI ilm animated
Transformers movie what can you tease
about Elita
I believe that's a character yes I'm
playing Lolita
um what can I tease about it well I'm
working with Josh Cooley who is an
incredible writer director who I adore
and have worked creatively with in in
other weight capacity and um it's you
know I think the film does it doesn't
look like anything I've ever seen before
it looks so cool it's just got such
every it's the texture of it is so is so
awesome I think it's and it because Josh
wrote it has it just feels very
I don't know it feels it's got a great
like dramatic feeling about it's funny
but it's got so much heart to it like
all of his stuff does
um I I don't know I just I think it's a
different way of approaching the
this you know uh uh IP I think it'll
it'll I think it stands on its own it's
pretty exciting yeah I mean my uh
there's not much I really can't say but
uh I'm just excited about it and uh I'm
it's a fun it was a great experience I
loved working with them we started doing
that before this movie
um so it's been a lot you can't say one
single thing well I can say uh I can say
a few things
um
bigger
better
Holier no
yes
no I haven't pulled my body I um I uh
yeah it's just I think it's you know
what the truth is this it's uh really
fun because it's as you know it's part
one and two and so it's it's a really
cool
um rare opportunity to get to tell one
big story and have the time to go into
all these things and to let these
characters really develop so I I look I
can't wait for it I'm so excited on that
note I'm gonna say thank you both for
your time thank you